Um,
I don't think there's a version where Donald Trump wins slow
is there. Let's see let's review.
So there are three States that are going to count votes more slowly. Um,
and those three States are the States that you don't want them to be.
They are Michigan, Wisconsin, and Pennsylvania. So, uh,
so you can imagine.
Hang on one sec, let's just, let me,
let me do this for anybody who is listening, who doesn't understand,
doesn't follow politics. Doesn't know what the going on. Like there's like,
I want to play dumb, cause I used to be really dumb on this.
So just for context real quick, I want your there's so much noise out there.
Andrew. I hopefully break this down for you.
There's 538 total electoral college votes.
You need 270 votes to win and essentially a lot of them are already baked.
So there's really like 201 votes up for grabs. Um,
because 330, one of them are so already locked. Um,
so with that context, Andrew take away, um,
it didn't mean I meant to interrupt you, but, uh, but only because if there's,
um.
The path is two 70. Yeah, completely. Yeah.
I was assuming that folks know that in Michigan, Pennsylvania,
Wisconsin are swing States or battleground States. Uh,
and so those three States not having their votes in on election night,
uh, will likely present a problem.
Like it's not a situation where you can pencil them in as blue or
red. Um, so if we're going to get a quick result on election night,
it's going to not involve those three States. Right? Uh,
it's very hard for me to imagine a scenario where Pennsylvania in particular is
just so clearly for one candidate that they call it.
Despite the fact that a lot of votes haven't been counted. Um, I like,
I don't see them calling Pennsylvania, uh,
or Michigan or Wisconsin for that matter.
There was one poll that came out that had Joe Biden up by 17 in
Wisconsin. So, so it's conceivable, that was constant.
Just goes so much for Joe that even with the mail-in vote, not, uh,
entirely counted that people are comfortable calling it. Um,
still something that I see as unlikely. So election night scenarios,
you have to contemplate them without knowing any of those three States, uh,
results. Uh, Joe has, uh,
an advantage in paths to two 70. He has a lot more paths to get there.
Trump needs to essentially win every state that he needs to win to get to two
72 70 is close to his ceiling.
There is a world where Joe Biden's ceiling is three 50,
like where he's just running by a mile. Um,
so the main scenario for Joe to become the clear
winner Tuesday night is if some of the big,
um, battleground States that are not those three go to him. Um,
so let's say Florida, North Carolina, if Florida and North Carolina go to Joe,
then he might be able to get to two 70,
even without any of the three slower States.
There's seven States. I think that really matter.
Uh it's you just said a bunch of them, but it's Michigan, Wisconsin,
Pennsylvania, Ohio, Florida, North Carolina, Arizona, that's, you're looking at,
and essentially Biden wins three of those it's over. Um,
and if he wins Florida, it's pretty much over all in, right? If,
if he wins just Florida by the numbers that won't happen,
he'll probably want any one of the others, but if he wins Florida,
it's probably pretty much close to over. Um, Trump needs five.
So that's where the like Biden his favorite is because of basically that math.
These are all toss ups, leaning Joe in many cases. Um,
so I think the likely path and when near you agree with, like,
if you had to guess the likely path, if either of them win, um,
the likely path for Joe to win is that he takes Michigan, Wisconsin,
Arizona, and probably Pennsylvania.
Cause in all of those he's favored,
he's got an 85 to 94% chance of winning
all four of those, you know, individually. Um, and then Trump,
if he wins, he basically has to win Florida, North Carolina, Ohio,
which he's winning in and then he'd have to take Pennsylvania and then one
of whatever's next either. And you could probably throw exactly.
And so if so Florida North Carolina go to Joe, it's pretty much all she wrote.
Yeah. That's the key. Yeah.
So that comes in election night.
Then we go to sleep knowing that Joe is going to be president and,
uh, the transition occurs hopefully pretty straightforwardly where if it's that
clean, it's going to be very hard for Donald Trump, not to concede. Um,
I know that some people in the Biden campaign are actually strategizing around
trying to get a quick knockout, uh,
by investing more heavily in Florida and North Carolina though,
they had beat campaign in Pennsylvania.
So they're then leaving nothing to chance that they're not,
they don't seem to be over emphasizing the timing of the thing.
They just want to win, which is the right approach. You know,
you're just going to win.
So you've got so Florida, according to five 38, which I think is the,
they were the closest essentially at least put in public press outlets because
they aggregate all the polls and just do an algorithm.
They're the closest to predicting 2016.
They said Hillary had a 71% chance of winning where the rest of the press said
it was well into the high nineties. Um,
they were saying that biding has a 62% chance of winning Florida
and um, 64% chance of winning North Carolina. Those are tossups.
Those are, you know, it's roll the die. Um,
it's going to come down to turnout and possibly some shenanigans with,
uh, mail-in voting or COVID voting if you will.
Um, but that's where you agree. I mean, like we're saying,
that's where we focus and if Biden wins,
one of those it's great Florida in particular, we're going to have a,
Biden's gonna have a good night. We agree. Yeah.
Uh, so that, that's where you should be, um,
investing in paying attention, uh, certainly on election night. Um,
and you should not hold your breath waiting for Pennsylvania, Wisconsin,
or Michigan and not, don't worry about it.
Like the fact that those aren't going to be reported. Doesn't tell you that, uh,
Joe is going to win or not win. Um, there.
It's not over either. Sorry to be clear, like if I lose North Carolina, Florida,
he's still got plenty of paths to victory. Sorry. Yeah.
And that is a possibility.
Historically North Carolina has been tougher terrain for
Democrats and, uh, Florida to slightly, uh,
I am very confident that Joe is going to win this thing. Uh,
I'm not sure if it's going to be Tuesday night reporting style. Uh,
but I'm very confident that he's going to win this thing if votes are counted
and the process holds up. Uh, so there,
so the let's consider again, each of them in turn, there,
there are a number of variables though.
Some of the variables extend beyond election night.
So I guess we'll just focusing on election night.
So you're right to look at the map, uh, as the election returns come in,
definitely it's going to be very exciting. Um,
but if these States start getting called for Joe, then that's enormous. Uh,
and there is a real chance that,
that there's a blue wave all around the country. I genuinely think that,
um,
in a time when 70 to 80% of Americans think that the worst time in
their lifetimes, that that's not like an incumbent type atmosphere, uh,
you know,
especially when this incumbent does not seem like the guy who's going to lead
you out your mind. So I think there's going to be a blue wave. I think, uh, the,
the democratic majority in the house is going to grow. Um,
the Senate's going to flip, um, there's going to be a unified government.
That's the way I think this is going to go as we're having this conversation,
like, you know, 75 million Americans have voted already. Uh,
and by the time people are hearing this on Monday,
it's going to be a significantly larger number.
And then everyone's going to turn out on Tuesday. Uh, so you're,
I saw projections that said that this is, might be the highest turnout, uh,
in 60 years because of mail-in voting and early
voting. I think we should keep mailing voting and early voting.
I think it works better.
I know who wants to just have everything be banking on everyone showing up at
the same time.
One day, they're just throwing me off. Yeah. Agreed. We,
so you have to imagine New York man. Right? So it's, there's a lot of them,
so yeah. So.
You have to imagine an incredibly high turnout environment and that's generally
going to help Dems. Um,
so the size and enormity of the blue wave
and whether it crashes down in places like Texas and Alaska and
South Carolina, Georgia,
so interesting to me, uh,
this really could redefine the American political landscape, uh,
for a long time. I mean, if Texas goes blue.
Well that's easy Texas go it's it's over. Uh.
Oh yeah. That would be incredible. Uh that's I don't necessarily expect that.
Sorry, Beto. I expect it to be very, very tight. Um, but I,
I doubt it's going to get called for Joe, um, Tuesday night, but if it were to,
yeah, it's over, I'll just call it.
Let's call it. Um, the, so let me ask you this,
like what's going to happen is you're going to start having,
you're gonna have a with, you're gonna have these state States.
I mentioned start reporting some results cause they're gonna be counting.
And I think turnout models gonna be all over the map. Right.
It's people are gonna be afraid to your point. I think you have record.
I think you have turned out like we've never seen before from people all and on
both sides. Yeah. I think Dems, maybe net benefit,
but Republicans get a lot of turn out too. If you start to see, like,
I,
I kind of want your perspective on how to help our listeners watch the results
come in on election night when they start to see Wisconsin numbers come in.
When you know, they're going to take a couple of days to tally everything. Like,
do they, like, you know,
let's say it's 25% of results are in and they start announcing,
do you feel comfortable with that? Do you, uh, does that mean nothing?
Cause it's gonna flip on the next 75.
It gets very frustrating. Zach has just depends upon where the 25% is from. Um,
if it's 25% from an urban area in Wisconsin,
then you'd expect it to skew very heavily democratic. And then, uh,
you take it with a massive grain of salt. If somehow they were to say to you,
this 25% is a representative cross-section of the whole state. Uh,
then statistically you could say, all right,
I guess we know what what's happening. Right.
That's one reason why they keep digging into which counties it's from,
because if you're an experienced political journalist, you know, which, uh,
which direction a County is supposed to go. Right? Um, the,
the thing I look for is results that surprise,
that surprised the journalist involved, where there someplace.
And they were like, well, I remember during the weekend,
after super Tuesday where they were digging into what was happening in Ann
Arbor, Michigan, uh, and they were like, Bernie,
doesn't win this County by like a million votes or whatever, you know,
then it's going to be a really rough night. Um,
so it's that kind of thing where if they can find an anomaly, um,
then that's a sign. Uh, but the, the raw vote totals, uh,
it's hard to tell because you don't know what counties are coming from.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.